[Music]  some people believe if we repeat stories  often enough they become real  [Music]  they make us who we are that can be  scary Harold  [Music]  you want to see haunted house  some kids went missing so they boarded  it up  okay I saw it we go now toward the  chicken  what's that it's a book of scary stories  tell me a story hey what's going on  Tommy's missing Tommy's name was in the  book there's no way it's actually  connected right okay what is what  happens in the book is exactly what's  happened for real oh my god listen  you're in the next story reading it  right here I'm afraid that we broke  something up you shouldn't have taken  the book  we've got to stop it  sara bellows his book when the stories  write themselves and it all comes alive  the Jing man is coming  [Music]